the beyonder is back ladies and
gentlemen and that's not even the main
thing that happens in this story this
story is crazy or at least this issu is
crazy right so here's what this does
this initially opens up with the
Avengers facing off against a guy named
the autocrat he doesn't matter he's
ultimately defeated by She-Hulk whatever
who cares the thing about this is this
story takes place immediately after the
events of allout Avengers we didn't
cover the entirety of that because there
were only select moments in that story
that were important we'll talk more
about that later on when we get to the
main villain the is being introduced
here who's basically the new God of
Marvel Comics it's crazy but what ends
up happening is that once the autocrat
is overtaken The Avengers are brought by
Iron Man and tala to a new room that
they've never seen before in Avengers
Tower and the thing about this is that
even when the Avengers say like we've
never been in this room before the
response of Iron Man and Black Panther
is neither have we now if you guys
noticed there's like this kind of
monologue that's being offered right
these blue squares with white letters
that is the beyonder talking we know
that from all lot Avengers we know the
beyonders back we've known that for a
while but the thing about this is he's
always kind of talking about how like
there's a main event that's taking place
something that's transpiring and what
he's been doing or had been doing during
the events of allout Avengers is
altering reality Around The Avengers
themselves to create these weird and
wonky circumstances in the hopes of
changing their perception of the world
and kind of bringing their mind to newer
Heights so they can face off against
greater threats than they've ever
encountered before one of the things to
remember is that at the end of allout
Avengers Captain America fig figured out
the beyonder was the one who had been
manipulating reality around them right
there was literally this moment where he
was standing in a room by himself and
directly addresses the beyonder because
he was seemingly the only one who had
ever done anything like this before from
Secret Wars 1 and Secret Wars 2 so the
mo made perfect sense and So what had
happened here is Black Panther and Iron
Man had basically worked on this system
that would be able to detect an energy
source and then force that energy source
to enter into its physical form the
problem here is that any time the
Avengers came close in The All Out
Avengers storyline to figuring out that
beyonder was the one behind all this he
would alter reality around them again so
they would basically lose whatever
momentum they' gained and so by working
separately as far as the beyonder was
concerned they were just kind of doing
individual things and working on
individual projects and he was none the
wiser secretly they were working on two
halves of the same machine and they
basically pressed a button when they
were completed and the Machine
teleported to this current location and
effectively assembled itself and then
once the Beyond realizes what's going on
it's too late the machine's turned on
and the beyonder is yanked out and
pulled into a physical form now here's
the thing about this right for those of
you guys who are not not familiar with
the beyonder this guy is as close as you
get to God as anybody ever has been in
the history of Marvel Comics there's two
versions of beyonder right you have
what's called pre rcon beyonder and the
modern day beyonder PR rcon is the level
of power he had in secret Wars 1 and
Secret Wars 2 before you get to the
unofficial Secret Wars 3 you'll find a
link to that playlist down in the
comments section so you can basically
see exactly what I'm talking about and
understand the change that Marvel made
when they reduced his power but one of
the things that Jonathan Hickman had
done and Avengers and New Avengers is he
had returned both the beyonder and the
beyonders his whole race back to the
level of power they had at the beginning
of all things which is why you saw the
beyonders wiping out the cosmic entities
at the end of Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers run literally
was a massacre H Pimp's just like out in
space trying to find out where the
incursions like how it's all starting
and he sees the beyonders killing like
eternity Infinity Oblivion master order
Lord Chaos they kill the Living Tribunal
it's nuts it's one of the most insane
moments ever in the history of the comic
oh God I love that point in Marvel
Comics but the thing about this is that
once the Beyond reemerges he immediately
panics and starts to freak out because
what he says is you have no idea what
you've done I've been trying to help you
I've been trying to help you by putting
you through the paces through all these
crazy escapades and whatnot giving you
different levels of power or different
tools that you can use because you have
no clue what's coming coming there's a
reason I've been hiding and I'm hiding
from that guy that's something to
understand here the beyonder this being
of astronomical power is hiding from
someone because they're so much more
powerful than he is that he can't even
begin to compare and that's when he
starts to spill the beans on what's
going on right he says before the
Omniverse came into being there was the
lost one The Lost One created the
beyonders much like they would later do
with me he imbued my people with the
tiniest fraction of his power he watched
with interest as my people grew jealous
and then resentful and he watched as
they plotted against him when they
attacked he allowed it curious to see
what would happen this turned out to be
a mistake realizing too late the genuine
threat they posed the lost one could do
little as they stole the rest of its
power now there is something that I do
want to talk about here for a second and
that's Defenders Beyond by Al ying and
the reason for this is because this
story is not written by aling this is
written by Derrick Landy and the reason
why that's so important is because in
aling's Defenders beyond what he stated
is that the beyonders were actually
created by the celestials so we've got
an inconsistency here now what we don't
know and this is one of the things you
just kind of have to wait and see in
Marvel Comics is which one Marvel goes
with this summer actually I think it's
in the fall one of the big things that's
taking place this year is that Jonathan
Hickman is coming back to Marvel Comics
to basically write a story about
Marvel's Gods what in effect it seems
like he's going to do is completely
rework and restructure the nature of the
cosmic hierarchy in Marvel Comics so
we'll have a definitive understanding of
where people rank in terms of the level
of power they have who's Inc continuity
who's out of continuity that kind of
thing so all you can really do right now
if you are reading Marvel Comics is just
kind of take this as potentially one
possibility of where the beyonders
actually came from that neither answer
seems to be definitively right but what
is important here assuming that we take
this as an absolute truth is the
beyonders are not native to their own
source of power and this flies in the
face of every everything we know about
the beyonders right so a little bit of
explanation here for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with the nature of
the beyonders their power different
things like that when the beyonder was
first introduced in Marvel Comics he was
just kind of a one-off in the secret
Wars story and that was it but Secret
Wars proved to be so popular they
brought him back and then that was all
we really got right it was like the
beyonder secret Wars part two and that
was it it wasn't until you got to the
Fantastic Four story that was kind of
The Unofficial Secret Wars 3 that you
learned the beyonder is simply one
member of a race called the beyonders
and they exist Beyond all space and time
outside of the Multiverse now that was
kind of the standard going forward for
years there wasn't really any indication
or reconciliation between the beyonder
and the beyonders outside of the fact
that the beyonder was part of their race
and for whatever reason was interested
in the Multiverse in Marvel Comics when
Jonathan Hickman came along in Avengers
and New Avengers what he basically said
is the original beyonder from Secret
Wars the one you see here right now this
one was like a child right a baby more
or less that had kind of been created
inadvertently when the molecule man Owen
Reese had basically conducted this
experiment and created a cosmic CE queue
by accident and in doing so half the
energy went into Owen Reese the other
half went out and became the beyonder
the beyonder source of power was never
really explained it was always just a
level of powers that they had that made
them incredibly powerful aling and
Defenders Beyond explained that by
saying their level of power was given to
them by the celestials so that if
another war broke out between the
celestials the beyonders could put the
gabos on it right and just end the
threat like that so it wouldn't lead to
the destruction of the Multiverse again
and so it's just kind of been that way
ever since this is a whole new
explanation right the fact that there is
a singular being out there who had such
an astronomical level of power that the
beyonders stole that power from him and
then dispersed it among themselves and
used it for their own ends now the funny
thing about this is that as is explained
here the lost one cannot be
traditionally killed or destroyed in
seemingly any conceivable way we're not
told why we're simply just told that's
the case and so they basically
imprisoned him on a moon that existed
outside the Omniverse now one of the
things that I want to explain here is
that Marvel in more recent years
Omniverse and Multiverse are just two
words to describe the same thing it
didn't used to be that way the Omniverse
used to be a collection of multiverses
and in fact the Omniverse was kind of
The Unofficial comic book explanation
for the collection of the DC Comics
Multiverse and the spawn Multiverse and
the Marvel Multiverse and any other
Multiverse that exists out there as a
giant collection of multiverses but
again in this day and age Marvel seems
to be using Multiverse and Omniverse as
interchangeable terms but of course with
him being imprisoned what ended up
happening here is somewhere along the
line he basically broke out and that
what he's been doing is traveling around
the Multiverse killing any beyonder he
finds absorbing their power into himself
or any force that the beyonders send
after him in order to try to destroy him
but the bigger point the beyonder makes
is that he and his race are just fleeing
for their lives and hiding away from
this guy as best as they possibly can so
what we thought was at one point these
astronomically powerful gods are hiding
from someone even more powerful what I'm
hoping you're noticing here particularly
if you're reading Marvel as a whole and
have been for the last couple years the
entire hierarchy is being thrown in
disarray a good example the one above
all is no longer the most powerful being
in Marvel Comics anymore we know that
from Defenders Beyond right the crown or
whatever it is that he's called the
Enigma is the most powerful being out
there in Marvel right now but the funny
thing about this is that when they ask
when the Avengers ask so why are you
here the response to the beyonder is so
you can help me fight this war and the
Avengers are kind of like what are you
even talking about man like so you're
literally telling us so there is a guy
out there whose level of power dwarfs
the power of you and you were a guy who
popped up on the scene and like killed
death in our universe and the cosmic
entities had no choice but to go to the
molecule man Owen Reese and ask him for
help because they were helpless to stop
you right that took place in secret Wars
2 like you're that guy and you think we
can help you defeat this other dude what
are you talking about man like I mean if
we can find a peaceful resolution sure I
guess but like we can't win a war
against a force like that like what
could we do harsh language get the
Infinity Gauntlet cross our fingers and
hope for the best like I mean there's
nothing we can do here and the response
to the beyonder is simply I've given you
whatever tools you need to succeed but
in the midst of all this where he
initially allies himself with the
Avengers and says I will help you fight
this war and presumably I'll gather the
other beyonders and we will try to do
the same they're suddenly met by the
arrival of tiok now here's the thing
tiok was introduced in all out Avengers
issue number four but the reason why I
didn't cover it at the time is because
it didn't seem to serve a real purpose
the only thing that happened is like
tiok showed up and beat the crap out of
Carol Danvers which was kind of amazing
to see but all we saw with her was that
like at the end of the comic she had
approached just this crazy wild looking
dude who of course we now know to be the
lost one and like that was it there was
no context to the situation so it just
didn't really make any any sense to
cover it at the time but the idea behind
this is that tmok is basically an
emissary of the lost one as it was
explained in Avengers Beyond number four
she's like his right hand right so like
his top person that he basically sends
out but the funny thing about this is
that Thor stands to her alongside Carol
Danvers and this girl crushes them both
this is what's so wild about this right
under any normal circumstance a villain
showing up and facing off against the
Avengers I mean it's cool and you get to
see like a bit of a battle this girl
it's not even really a battle so much as
Child's Play right it's her just kind of
keeping herself entertained as the
moment this chick isn't even really
trying but she single-handedly crushing
the entirety of the Avengers by herself
but ultimately she ends up achieving her
goal and this happens when she pulls a
dagger and is able to cut the beyonder
and when that happens as he bleeds she
says it's done that because of her
actions here that basically injuring him
his blood has now spilt in the Physical
Realm which means now she literally says
if you use your powers in any way right
if you leave this planet's atmosphere he
will know he will know exactly where
you're at so the best thing you can do
here is to stay and hide now this may
seem arbitrary it may seem like Derrick
Landy is kind of pulling this out of
nowhere this is actually not true he's
borrowing a page out of the old silver
server comics from back in the day and
anybody who's familiar with Marvel
Comics would tell you that so for those
you guys who don't know in the original
Galactus Trilogy in the Fantastic 4 when
Galactus first popped up at the end of
the story The Silver Surfer actually
turned against him and so what it did is
it forced Galactus or at least drove
Galactus to imprison the Silver Surfer
on Earth and what it did is that kicked
off the Silver Surfer solo Series where
he was basically traveling around the
world working alongside different
superheroes learning about Humanity
things like that it was a resoundingly
successful and even to this day still
holds up as a phenomenal comic book it's
amazing but this is where dck land's
getting this from right quite literally
beyonder is made a prisoner of Earth
more so than that and kind of what feeds
into the plot he can't necessarily use
his powers but he can't say okay well
then I'll snap my fingers and I'll help
you guys defeat this guy and we'll call
together all the different ones so on
and so forth instead he has to go back
to his incorporeal form and just kind of
remain in hiding at different places on
Earth and that's it because the instant
he leaves that's all there is to it now
where tiok is locked up by the Avengers
and basically put inside of a prison
that'll basically hold her the main
concern The Avengers have now is what's
going to happen if this guy sends more
forces after us and that's exactly what
he's doing specifically the lost one is
sending a reformed and presumably
cosmically Amplified version of the Cole
obsidian super giant black dwarf the
ebony ma corvis glaive these guys are
all coming after him so it's going to be
kind of amazing now what this does is
this picks up with the Avengers fighting
the black order and for the most part
everybody here is recognizable to you if
for no other reason than infinity War
The Only Exception would be Black Swan
and unless you've read Marvel Comics you
don't know who she is black Swan's part
of the black order she has been for
quite some time she's basically Valeria
Richards the daughter of Reed Richards
from an alternate reality she's really
powerful but under normal circumstances
I wouldn't care about the Avengers
fighting the black order I'm telling you
about this so you understand what
happens next because the Avengers are
about to get
wrecked and not even by a little bit
right not even by a little bit so the
funny thing about the black order is
they're easily an Avengers level threat
right they go toe-to-toe with these guys
and it really is just a knockdown drag
out fight and for the most part The
Avengers are able to hold their own now
one of the things to understand that's
been going on here and this is something
that we talked about in the last video
all of this is based around the concept
of the Lost one in Marvel Comics which
is to say a newly introduced being who's
responsible for the beyonders getting
their power he's this guy that's just
astronomically powerful I mean being
able to alter reality on like a
multiversal scale the beyonders rebelled
against him stole his power and then
locked him away he ultimately escaped
and he's been traveling through the
universe and even the Multiverse trying
to find the beyonders and kill them
everywhere he can the black hoarder
being here is a result of them being
summoned in kind of brought in by the
lost one himself but the kicker behind
all this is there's a great big huge
kind of barrier that surrounds the Earth
that was really created with the
assistance of the beyonder to keep the
lost one out it's not going to work
because while the Avengers were able to
overcome the black order at the end of
the day Captain America calls out to the
beyonder because remember the beyonder
originally appeared warned the Avengers
of the lost one and then took off but
Captain America knows the beyonder can
hear him because the beyonder is kind of
watching everything that's going on even
if you can't physically see him but the
thing about this is The Shield suddenly
goes down and then the lost one shows up
now leaving out the fact that this guy
looks like Super Shredder this dude is a
hoss an absolute Hoss here's the funny
thing about this man it's like this
amazing moment because as The Avengers
are standing there right Captain America
Captain righteous is like you're not
taking one step further this dude
doesn't say a word and takes one step
further Iron Man blast him with with
this energy blast all the Avengers jump
in this guy's like man son you better
come strong this guy punches Thor sends
him flying levels Captain Marvel in one
shot takes out Captain America in one
hit just like knocks this guy to the
ground Thor jumps back in with another
hit gets blasted into the ceiling done
like it's it's one of those crazy
moments it's just it's amazing to see
this happen so what this guy does is he
basically walks up to water four
crystals takes them and then basically
proceeds to leave Now The Avengers try
to rally themselves and try to go back
in on the assault only for them to
realize the shields back up again and
that's when it dods on Captain America
when the beyonder showed up here and the
beyonders said I will help you guys
basically build a shield that will keep
out the lost one you can Marshall your
forces you can bring together whatever
Powers you need to in order to defeat
this guy I mean good luck right because
as the beyonders we killed all the
cosmic entities including the Living
Tribunal this guy is more powerful than
us so hey man uh I don't know what to
tell you right like what he realizes is
when the shield goes back up it was
never about the be under helping them it
was about the beyonder setting a trap it
was the beyonder lowering the shield so
the lost one would come in collect the
four crystals and then in turn the
shield would go back up and keep him
trapped on Earth with nowhere to go and
so following this the beyonder Alters
reality within earth and then creates
like a whole another set of Avengers
which initially fight against the main
Avengers themselves it's a little funny
it's kind of interesting it's not overly
significant but then the group basically
turns its sights on the lost one and of
course once the fight breaks out again
they all get crushed again right you
think they would have learned their
lesson the first time but then like the
beyonder himself shows up and initially
he goes to challenge the lost one right
he says like greetings my fearsome
friend I am Yonder The bootleg
beyonder what manner of being might you
be right because it's like the bootleg
Avengers this guy just snatches him up
right and it's just like no we're not
doing this right this this game's over
and once the fight's back on again of
course the Avengers taken out quite
readily I mean they're just they're
demolished and so the funny thing here
is that this guy takes off his helmet he
realizes the main beyonder himself is
still out there the bootleg beyonder was
just like a fa simile and this guy flies
out to the very edge of the barrier he
can't pass it but he flies out to the
very edge of the barrier and then starts
talking to the beyonder and just says
like you have my power I want it back
now one thing to remember here is that
once The Lost One was on the Move what
the beyonder told us is that all the
other beyonders across existence were
just fleeing for their lives that's
literally the best they could do that
was the best they could hope for was to
just run and hope they didn't get caught
because the instant this guy got a
portion of its power back it was more
than enough to take out any one
particular beyonder and so tracking them
down individually they never had a
chance the funny thing here is the
entirety of this barrier and the entire
basis behind how it ex exist comes by
way of all the beyonders appearing now a
little bit of explanation here we
probably should have done this earlier
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with the beyonders again they're
ridiculously overpowered they come from
the Beyond ver there are different
variations of their origin in Marvel
Comics you can just kind of go with
whatever origin you want to but again
like we mentioned earlier in Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers they
killed all the cosmic entities one
beyonder in a single Universe was
powerful enough to wipe out every Cosmic
entity galatis The celestials Eternity
Infinity the whole nine yards three
beyonders were powerful enough to
destroy the Living Tribunal the living
embodiment of the Multiverse and what's
supposed to be the second most powerful
being in existence after the one above
all In This Moment here we've got four
not only that the lost one's more
powerful than them just to give you guys
perspective here now the nature behind
the crystals is that they are in fact
beyonders themselves and that's what the
main beyonder did is he basically used
the crystals or used beyonders condense
them down to an almost crystalline form
and then basically have them operating
as a kind of source of power for the
nature of the shield imprisoning The
Lost One using the power of the
beyonders themselves now where the other
beyonders show up here and they really
kind of chastise him for his actions the
response of the lost one is like I'm
going to kill every single one of you
you are all going to die and he can do
it too well at least if he never get
past the shield and in fact what the
beond say is exactly that your Shield is
imperfect beyonder it's only a matter of
time before someone with enough power
manages to break through it this guy
might not necessarily be able to do it
but somebody will and when that happens
all hell's going to break loose right
it's going to be an absolute Calamity
and so following that they basically
tell him what you've done here until
such a time as someone's able to break
through this Shield you've effectively
saved our people from complete and total
Annihilation but we cannot ignore the
fact that you have attacked one of your
own or at least your own people
themselves you attack them you confine
them to a state of living death and they
will stay here on Earth forever
operating as a source of power for a
barrier to try to keep this guy trapped
so you beyonder are banished from your
kind you are no longer welcome to us as
the beyonders they strip him of his
power literally take away every ounce of
power that this guy has they say you
will be confined back to a human form
and you will be sent back to Earth they
cast him down so this guy goes crashing
down to the surface and the beyonder is
now human now of course the question has
to be asked what in the world happens
next this video will explain that but we
do a bit of a Time skip between the end
of the last video that we did and the
start of this one and what's basically
happened is the lost one has effectively
wiped out most of the superheroes on
Earth or at least defeated them and
really even killed a whole bunch of them
and in fact one of the big things that
you guys kind of asked was was that if
this guy is so powerful why doesn't he
just like do what some kind of crazy
reality whoer would do and just alter
all things in existence or something
along those lines well the way this is
answered and I'm curious to see how you
feel about it is we're basically just
told power has limits right this body I
wear though I fashioned it myself is
still only its capable as that for which
it was designed when I first conjured it
eons ago from matter and energy it was
for all intents and purposes perfect I
could swim on the surface of a sun I
could fly through a black hole I could
shatter a moon with my fist and then my
power was stolen from me by beings that
are called the beyonders and that he's
basically been trapped in this body ever
since the bigger Point that's being made
here is that those individuals who can
alter reality or who have insane levels
of Power are largely limited by the
bodies in which they occupy which
actually makes sense and in fact that's
been a case in Marvel Comics for quite
some time it wasn't really overtly
stated the way that it's being stated
right now but it was one of those things
you just kind of came to understand
right Franklin Richards could do all
kinds of fantastic stuff alter reality
on a universal scale Mt Jim Jaspers
could do the same thing Matthew Malloy
could do it to a degree but he
resurrected himself from the dead and we
never really got the full totality of
what he was capable of but any one of
these guys if they were without a body
would be able to achieve ridiculous
things in Marvel Comics hence the nature
of embodies when it comes to the cosmic
entities if you don't know what that is
we'll talk about that here in a little
bit but the thing about this is that
what we saw at the end of the last video
is that as part of a kind of quote
unquote punishment which is to say when
the beyonders had initially stolen the
power of the lost one for themselves and
they in turn started perusing the cosmos
that what the main beyonder had done in
order to keep the lost one trapped on
Earth is he had kidnapped other
beyonders and then basically used them
as a kind of prison system siphoning off
their energy and so on but in effect he
turned against his own kind the result
was that his power was stripped away
from him by the other remaining
beyonders and then he was cast down to
earth and that's why here in this moment
when he's approached by the lost one he
talks about how he doesn't remember
anything he doesn't have his powers he
doesn't know how the shield works or any
of that stuff because he doesn't right
like all that stuff was taken away from
him the idea behind the main beyonders
themselves is that they would basically
have the lost one trapped here on Earth
and that would effectively be it and so
what we end up doing is picking up in
the room of what used to be the city of
New York again we never really saw how
New York fell we just kind of jumped
forward to after it was basically
destroyed and She-Hulk was tattered and
so on and so forth the big thing here
though is that what they had discovered
is that before the beyonder had
encountered the lost one in this story
what he had done was taken a portion of
his memory and put it within New York
City itself underground so that if
something were to happen he could
basically attain this portion of his own
memory and then figure out exactly what
needs to be done done to set things back
to rights exactly why he did it I'm not
entirely sure and it looks like it's
being done just for the sake of being
able to tell the story but of course the
Avengers kind of ask him what do you
know about the lost one he of course
reveals the lost one's name as being
calora which we already know and that
the question is is there a way to lower
the shield to get this guy off of our
planet now what Iron Man also does is he
Fashions a device to this orb that the
beyonders memory is currently sitting in
and when the lost one shows up he
deduces that the nature of this item
this artifact is that it will basically
blow the orb up and destroy the memory
of the beyonder should the lost one
choose to use his powers and so what you
get is this really interesting Quagmire
here this really interesting situation
the lost one's been around for countless
eons right at the end of the day the
Avengers are just like superheroes on
Earth who do superhero things because
that's what superheroes do but depending
on where you stand in the philosophy and
morality of superheroes you could see
their goodness as a weakness and that's
how the lost one sees it right his
stance when sheho whole kind of freaks
out when he says like are we here to
Banter or are we here to fight she makes
this statement and saying you killed
thousands of innocent people and his
response is actually it was tens of
thousands if you're going to talk about
what it was that I did at least get it
right right I mean I killed tens of
thousands of people not just like
thousands of people and where Thor
responds in saying we do not negotiate
with murderers the response to the lost
one is but of course you do to save
yourselves and your planet you do it all
the time is what I ask unreasonable or
just merely distasteful what makes this
situation different than any of the
countless others where you've made
Bargains with villains where you've done
all kinds of things to work alongside
villains in order to make sure that your
schemes came to fruition a really good
example of this is during like the
incursions the collapse of the
Multiverse once you got to that
situation and everything was popping off
there was no differentiation between
hero and villain it was just people who
were trying to survive during the events
of Civil War right you had the superhero
community that was split down the middle
there were no heroes or villains there
it was simply people who were against
registration and for registration so
there's been multiple instances over the
case of Marvel Comics where heroes in
the traditional sense are willing to
cast aside their own morality for the
sake of a greater cause and that's the
point that he makes he says you value
your principles and your honor but these
are words and Concepts and intangible
things with the luxury of choice they
are indeed to be protected but people
there's no choice when it comes to
protecting people that is what Heroes do
so when you have to choose between
giving me the knowledge I seek I.E how
to lower the shield thus betraying your
principles or watching as I Slaughter
your mortal population you will grit
your teeth and give me what I want and
that's the accurate statement that's
really exactly what would happen here
that the idea of the Avengers standing
with their arms on their hips in this
Superman pose and saying we're good guys
and we we do good things and no way
we're going to give ground to a villain
it's standing on ceremony right it's
political Grand standing and really
nothing more now the cool thing about
this is that in response to that Captain
America suddenly shows up kind of
longing for a fight it doesn't amount to
much but he does come with a bit of a
caveat and this is where we explain the
nature of like the celestials and all
this kind of different stuff right so
for those of the guys who don't really
know what embodies are in Marvel Comics
when it comes to Cosmic entities
eternity Infinity any number of these
guys with the exception of galatis if
we're being honest they have no physical
form right like they just kind of
represent ideas when a cosmic entity
wants to appear with a physical form it
travels to a place called the dimension
of manifestations which is home to a
being called anthropomor this was
explained in the old quazar Comics back
in the early 1990s back when Greg capula
was drawing at Marvel for those of you
guys who read the Batman run and didn't
know that uh but when this happens of
course they get a physical form then
they appear and that's basically it with
regards to the celestials and how they
function in all of this the idea behind
this is that in recent years in Marvel
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with this the beyonders were just like
beings who existed out there beyond the
Multiverse and that's all we ever really
got what ended up happening during Al
Ying's really Defenders Beyond and even
the main Defender story is we learned
that the beyonders were created by the
celestials due to the celestial holy war
that happened at the very beginnings of
all creation and the idea was that if
for some reason the celestials in any
one particular Universe went to war
against themselves again the beyonders
would be able to step in with this
astronomical amount of power that they
have and they would stop the fight
between the celestials potentially even
wiping out the entire universe so they
were created as a kind of checks and
balance that's why when Captain America
shows up here he's drenched in Celestial
blood because what the statement is
that's made here is it's simply that the
beyonders and even the lost one got his
power from the celestials but there was
a caveat built into it which is that
they cannot actually harm celestials
unless the celestials are Waging War
against each other so kind of like a
magical binding or a power-based binding
or something along those lines is this
being done as like a giant plot device
for the story absolutely it 100% is
being done that
way right but it does tie in very neatly
to what it is well maybe not neatly but
it does tie in to what aling has
covering with Defenders Beyond or at
least what he did cover with that story
now transitioning over to the main
beyonder himself once he approaches his
memory his idea is to basically work
directly with the memory absorb it into
himself and then in turn he'll recall
everything that the lost one needs to
know it will not be a return to his
powers but it will give him the
information that he needs now such as it
is when it comes to the lost one
fighting Captain America with all this
Celestial blood on his body it really
kind of just comes down to a hand toand
fight he does use things like optic
blast and so on and so forth or shooting
lasers out of his eyes or whatever you
want to call it but it's not really
using like the vast power that's at his
disposal and so the result of this is
that the fight happens kind of the way
that you would expect it to right just a
good oldfashioned knockdown drag out
fight but in the midst of all this the
beyonder steps up and then stops the
whole thing and says I will tell you
exactly what it is that you want to know
but you have to agree to give me back my
power I want to become one with the
cosmos again and ultimately The Lost One
agrees right that what ends up happening
is the lost one scans the mind of the
beyonder learns how to effectively shut
down the shield and then absorbs all the
power of the three beyonders who were
serving as a battery for the shield into
himself he's not as powerful as he used
to be but he's a lot more powerful than
he was at the beginning of this story
and so when the beyonder says return my
power to me the lost one says okay and
then literally just kind of
disintegrates him right dissipates him
to where he goes back to becoming one
with the cosmos he just doesn't really
have a physical form anymore he could
reconstitute it at some point in time if
he chose to so it's just a way for
Marvel to put his character on the back
burner until they decide to bring him
back again but then like tala shows up
with the blood of the celestial on him
and there is a little bit of a fight
there but the big question that's really
being asked is are you going to leave
this world you need to get out of here
now the lost one is really kind of
operating with a bit of a vendetta which
is to say like I mean I'm really half
inclined to just wipe out your whole
earth if for no other reason than the
fact that you guys were just
inconveniencing me right so I think I
might do that now this is where the
Avengers arguably make a bluff and what
they say is that there are satellites
that are orbiting the Earth right now
that are powered with Celestial energy
right Celestial technology and they're
targeted directly at you you do not have
the ability to stop the full power of
celestial energy that's just not going
to happen right like you were made by
the celestials you can presumably be
unmade by the celestials which really
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense if
their whole job was to stop the
celestials but the fact remains right
we're going to destroy you using these
satellites initially he doesn't believe
them but initially he dismisses it right
like I detect no Celestial infused
satellites and I do not believe that you
would kill 8 million people not even to
save 8 billion this is a bluff and the
response of Captain America is actually
really genius here it's like maybe it is
maybe it isn't maybe the celestial
technology hides their presence from you
do you really want to take that risk are
you going to gamble your life and your
entire existence on the idea of proving
us wrong right if that's really what you
want to do then sure right we can fire
the satellite off that may or may not be
there and we can just see what happens
right like we'll eradicate 8 million
people on our world to save 8 billion
people you'll be dead and at the end of
the day hey you know maybe it really is
a small price to pay for the greater
good now knowing superheroes as we know
them that's not going to happen and I
would bet nine times out of 10 that it
really is a bluff we never actually get
an answer to this instead the lost one
simply restores New York using his
powers and sets everything back to
rights following that he basically ends
up departing Earth as he agreed to do
and that's where the story ends with
that being said guys if you want to get
caught up on the rest of Avengers Beyond
which was a lot better than this ending
to be honest make sure you click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace